speaking of work ethic all right
you know there's a lot of people
throwing out this new idea there's a
congressman who actually implemented the
typical work week they're basically
saying five days that's still
something that we need to be doing is
there a better plan out there i want to
know what you guys think
in the comments about this five-day work
week potentially going down
to a four-day work week is the four-day
work week actually coming here to
america so look let me just frame this
like big picture you know people are out
of work covid global supply chain global
labor shortage companies can't find
workers the great resignation the great
reset the great reshuffle all this stuff
going on and basically is the answer a
four-day work week would you want to
work only four days a week now according
to a recent survey here done cnbc
in a recent survey a thousand workers
most americans say what david they said
yes of course we're down for a four-day
work week here's some of these stats
real quick
you could pull this up
question they asked this question are
you burned out let me know in the
comments if below by the way before i
get into this would you want a four day
work week right
or do you want to stick to your five day
work week yes
thumbs up four day work week no want to
stick to the typical five day work week
let me know below in the comments and
david thank you for monitoring all that
i got my guys sounds bye bye
uh in the house he's a good dude um
so anyway is a remedy a four-day
workweek here's the result of a recent
thousand person poll that this was on
cnbc most americans said yes get this so
are you burned out 53 percent of people
say overall yes they are experiencing
burnout so more than half said they are
experiencing burnout 56 of women
said they are experiencing burnout and
62 percent of gen z
your people david i'm not gen z yeah
you're the oldest gen z david you're 25.
95 1995. that's gen z dude i'm sorry
you're the the youngest millennial or
the oldest gen z take your pick now
oldest millennial okay youngest
millennials that's what i meant yeah
you're the oldest one i know we've got
the both opposite ends of this exactly
so gen z 62 basically saying they
weren't out burnt out they've been
working for like a year and a half now
two years they're burnt out
they're the highest no i mean if they're
18 they're doing construction i mean i
wouldn't doubt that a child is burnt out
from doing construction i mean you're
assuming that an 18 year old's doing
construction but i am i
could be working in retail they could be
working uh doing deliveries they could
be working at a lock clerk office they
could do anything yeah that's such a
thing because obviously if that's the
most they've ever worked and been like
this is so much horrible exactly it's
like don't ever spill milk that's why a
child cries that's the worst thing that
ever happened to that baby
you know what i'm saying all right so
the the question of being burnt out more
than half 53 overall said yes i'm burnt
out i'm experiencing burnout 56 of women
62 percent of gen z you're people that
you don't want to be affiliated with
and the answer that they asked would a
four day work week help 83 yes
83 yes sign me up for a four day workout
until there's
years decades of four day and then it's
like a third day working yes god four
days i only get three days four days
well it used to be seven days a week
until basically uh
you know labor laws back in my day
david's old man uh impersonation always
a go-to fan favorite
so then they said they said all right
that's what the employees had to say
let's talk to the employers yeah you're
gonna be shocked of what they said they
said would a four-day work week give
employers an edge when it comes to
hiring all right so there's competition
people aren't working what are you gonna
do to basically get people working for
you gotta give them a little perks we'll
talk about some of these perks in a
second but basically according to a 2019
report in the year 2019 from the henley
business school in the uk where your
people are from in the uk they said he's
affiliated with every good thing do you
love chelsea oh i love chelsea exactly
so according to this um business school
report in the uk they said 63 percent of
businesses
said it was easier to attract and retain
talent with the four-day workweek dude
absolutely okay
seventy-eight percent of employees
with the forty four day work schedules
are happier and less stress is what they
found so basically people are like dude
this five-day work week it's too much
for me let's scale it down to four days
so these are some of the stats that
they've shown but could this actually
happen
in the u.s so let's pull this thing up
and basically this article says don't
hold your breath buddy this ain't
happening
so recently a california congressman
named mark takano of course this happens
in california right
he introduced legislation to basically
implement a four-day work week basically
not just talking about it being about it
right introducing legislation four-day
work week and he basically cited this
article that in iceland
eighty percent of the work uh workforce
has a four day work week eighty percent
of the people in iceland do a four day
week week and then they basically said
that by the way just
to be fair you know how many people the
population of iceland
i don't think one random guess iceland i
don't know just to put it in perspective
just to put in perspective we have 330
something million people here in america
six million people six million how about
sixty six thousand kids [ __ ] up yeah
like they're marking many people in
iceland all right so this is not a great
sample size however they're doing four
day work weeks in iceland but you know
where the concept is catching on ladies
and gentlemen how about these countries
spain which they love their siestas
yes new zealand down under next to
australia and this is something we're
going to touch on japan
japan so are you familiar with some of
these uh japan is the number one most
overworked society in the world have you
seen some of these pictures uh japanese
workers sleeping i have not i just get
to the computer and open up tabs yeah
that's what you're gonna do that's what
the next one is so basically japanese
workers work so much that it's basically
not only encouraged but totally
acceptable to sleep on the streets take
a look at some of these pictures that
are going on here
just google japanese workers sleeping
this is how burnt out the people of
japan are this is that's exactly real
this is real can we scroll in on that
these are people sleeping
on the street
is it homeless or just burnt out
right
wow dude yeah this guy just collapsed
right now right there on the subway oh
this guy yeah this guy
[Laughter]
this guy got comfortable this guy said
take it all off buddy this guy either
got robbed or got really comfortable
yeah it's i i'm guessing very
comfortable keep going down this guy
with that neck that's not going to be
helpful neck bro
scroll down what's the article saying
over over tired japan is turning to
office yes yeah basically they're just
saying just sleep dude
they were crazy hours so basically this
is what burnout looks like this is what
we're trying to avoid they're at least
what they're trying to avoid in japan
now in america is this gonna happen as a
four-day work week until in america
unless we start seeing people working
this hard i don't see a four day work
week people won't even do a one day work
week in america today because they're
collecting unemployment still
okay and they're i mean i think
five percent of americans have basically
quit their jobs for good because they've
made that crypto wealth um
anyway this was introduced by this
congressman mark takano he introduced a
four-day work week we see what's going
on in japan so let's just break down
exactly what a four day work week would
entail so number one you'd be working 32
hours instead of 40. so even i asked a
question over here if you can work for
typical work week four days
um eight instead of eight hours a day
times five and you work 10 hours a day
times four would you do it most people
would say yes yeah three day weekends
baby who the hell doesn't want that
um so the perks are the exactly of what
a four-day workweek would be it would be
32 hours a week not 40.
you would get three day weekends for
sure friday's off
right
and get this it's the cherry on top baby
the cherry on top
the pay doesn't decrease you get the
same amount that you were getting paid
same out amount salary same amount per
hour as if you're working the five days
yeah we're working less hours so your
salary would decrease that apparently
not apparently not so they would
compensate because they're basically
saying
you can be more productive hear me out
this is according to the iceland study
of 366 000 they're basically saying
workers felt less stressed and less
burnt out no [ __ ] because you're only
working four days a week but also the
you improved quality of work you have
more energy
um you have better overall attitude like
thinking about it it's friday no it's
thursday like i am thursday
and when you get to work you know you
got to work fully present at work right
well yeah but it's doing your thing holy
[ __ ] i got four days to do this
exactly
so
the point is this this is what's this is
what they're they're they're presenting
this option and they're basically saying
look in iceland they do it eighty
percent of the workforce is doing it
it's happening in spain they're taking
siestas four day work weeks it's
happened in new zealand get a load of
freaking japan what the hell is going on
there people are sleeping on the streets
like it's homeless vibes good to go
but what did happen here in america i
don't know interesting concept
but i feel like if it happens in america
i mean i think like america is like a
symbol of work your ass off to make it
capitalism let's go baby not four day
work weeks enjoy your nap sleep in right
right i just
i feel like in america we got [ __ ] to do
uh we got and excuse me if i
mispronounce this eureko uh he goes
northern europeans are usually very
productive four-day work work days would
work however for us unproductive
southern europeans yeah it would not
work
so i guess what he's saying
yeah it works in some cases
it's funny that they say northern and
southern europe because that's sort of
like if you if you look at italy not
that i'm some the italian expert of the
renaissance but northern italy works
milan yeah florenza you know lake como
up there in the north they're closer to
switzerland northern european the people
down south
in capri
napoli they chilling they got their tan
on point they ain't working that hard
yeah they're lucky to do a three-day
work week down there up north five-day
work week
so interesting look i think more than
anything i saw this concept i'm like
this is something we can discuss this is
debate a viable debate to happen there's
going to be people saying
no five day work week that we got to get
[ __ ] done this is what it is obviously a
lot of employers are going to say that
employees have four day work week
so it comes down to the perspective
right
obviously everyone wants to have a
decent work-life balance you know pat
talks about this all the time pbd
work-life balance that guy works harder
than anybody i know that guy could be
chilling if he wanted to be but that
guy's grinding grinding grinding
basically
inspired me to kick my game up a notch i
was in chillin vibe for many years and
then i see this guy working i'm like
this guy's worth a hundred times more
than me
and he's still working harder than me
all right motivation right there right
so different perspectives employers are
gonna have different perspective
employees are gonna visit inspective but
basically
these are the types of things that are
being talked about to what attract
employees people aren't working these
days gotta get these people back to work
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken